[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs ravi de vous retrouver pour ce
sixième numéro tout de suite le sommaire
de ce jeudi 18 octobre
on tournait depuis deux ans la compagnie
madani s'arrête au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines jusqu'au 20
octobre dix femmes issus de quartiers
populaires se raconte
entre jeux danses et chants nous avons
assisté aux dernières répétitions de la
balade contée au stage de cuisine
asiatique le central près de nîmes en
pack d'activités pour les vacances aux
rivières nom sera avec nous pour nous
les présenter
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines accueille la première manche
de coupe du monde sur piste 19 au 21
octobre
françois perdu dingue rendez-vous pour
encourager l'équipe de france après les
hommes
ahmed madani offre la seine à 10 jeunes
femmes toutes ont des parents et qui ont
vécu l'exil et viennent de quartiers
périurbains
elles jouent chantent et dansent pour
raconter leur histoire avant et avec
elle les histoires de jeunes femmes
d'aujourd'hui avec manou varaldo nous
avons assisté à une répétition des
chaises pour dix jeunes femmes après
avoir donné la parole aux hommes dans
illuminations ahmed madani constitue le
deuxième volet de son aventure face à
leur destin
les deux spectacles vivants sont
inspirés des récits de ces jeunes issus
de quartiers populaires pour mettre la
vie moderne sur le plateau au premier
jour de répétition
la page est blanche c'est le principe
est un dialogue
qu'est ce qu'on fait est bon on se
raconte des histoires on est sur un don
et un contre dont le metteur en scène a
mis deux ans pour réunir son casting
moi je rappelle à décembre j'ai 28 ans
je ne pense pas représenter une
catégorie de personnes en tout cas pas
les pénélopes et ni les femmes voilées
parmi elles anissa à oreille est
originaire de montigny le bretonneux
après avoir joué dans une centaine de
théâtre dont une tournée en suisse
revenir à saint quentin en yvelines a un
goût particulier
en fait c'est chez moi gg je peux aller
n'importe où dans le monde
mais là où j'ai grandi c'est ici donc
forcément une forte émotion
nous professionnels à l'origine elle
joue
chante danse et livrent toute leur
puissance ces deux années dans la
compagnie madani leur ouvre de nouvelles
voies
ça m'a donné vraiment envie de continuer
à creuser en moi et là je me suis mise à
réaliser un documentaire qui est
primé par la fondation france
télévisions qui s'appelle les dents de
la barre un troisième volet réunissant
hommes et femmes devrait voir le jour
d'ici 2020 son nom incandescence vient
tout juste d'être décidé par ahmed
madani
[Musique]
ça y est elle est là révèle ce week-end
débutent les vacances scolaires de la
toussaint pour profiter de ce temps
libre en famille le centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux propose
des activités variées avec nous en
plateau aurélie arnaud bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes coordinatrice au centre
qui est toujours un bon niveau pour les
vacances tout à fait donc nous débutons
les vacances avec une balade contée pour
les tout-petits de samedi de 10h30 à
11h30 pour être qu'on pourra y trouver
dans cette ballade comptage
c'est une balade en famille à partir des
18 mois jusqu'à quatre ans où vous
seront déroulés des chansons des
histoires c'est charles atemi la souris
qui ceux qui le gèrent sage de santa fe
présent alors l'après midi il y aura des
jeux de société pareil en famille tout
le monde peut venir tout à fait ces deux
en famille pour adolescents excédés
également il ya des jeux classiques
comme des nouveautés et un goûter offert
tout l'après midi ils sont invités à
venir jouer et surtout la particularité
du centre c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
stages est ce qu'on peut nous expliquer
un peu différents stages il ya plein de
choses c'est très varié qui a un stage
de chant qui se déroulera du 22 au
mercredi 24 octobre
donc c'est pour les adolescents de 8 à
13 ans nous avons la récré d'alfred
aussi qui pour les tout-petits la récré
d'alfred c'est quoi c'est pour les du 4
4 à 6 ans et un pour permettre aux
parents de se rencontrer
laisser les enfants jouer avec une heure
de jeu prix conçus spécialement pour eux
on a aussi un nouveau stage qui fait son
nid
région centre c'est un stage de photo
pour les adolescents à partir de 13 ans
donc c'est pour apprendre à utiliser un
appareil photo reflex ou numérique
la prise de vue la réflexion autour de
la composition est également la retouche
photo
les ados tout à fait les adultes novices
également sont invités à se rejoindre ce
stage s'ils veulent participer et vivre
un moment avec leurs adolescents
nous avons aussi un stage de cuisine
asiatique au vu de ce succès nous avons
un premier stage du 23 au 25 octobre
mais aussi également du 29 et 30 octobre
donc là aussi des inscriptions sont
encore ouvertes pour ce second stage
cuisine asiatique
on va apprendre à faire plusieurs grands
plein à des tels faits a pris un art lac
et apprentissage été coupée découpage du
poisson cru pour les sushis sashimis que
c'étaient les grands classiques son rang
travailler avec un chef cuisiner qui a
l'habitude de travailler avec des
enfants ont le désir dit ça avait
beaucoup de succès parce qu'on peut
s'inscrire avant c'est ça tout à fait
les inscriptions sont ouvertes depuis
maintenant un mois et demi les stages
sont programmés suffisamment à l'avancé
pour que les parents puissent programmer
des vacances scolaires de leurs enfants
et si on s'y prend un peu tard est-ce
que c'est toujours possible tout à fait
que c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
ouvert un stage du 29 29 et 30 octobre
nous avons aussi un stage de découverte
de la poterie
donc c'est vraiment un stage de pour
mettre en avant l'activité qui est qui
se déroulent toute l'année scolaire
donc c'est pour découvrir toutes les
techniques utilisées par aurore qui qui
supervise tous les stages à l'année le
découvert de la poterie c'est à dire on
va découvrir quoi comment faire une
poterie tout à fait comme on l'a
fabriqué le
il réfléchit à réflexion autour d'un
objet d'art ou de l'utilisation hebdo
manne quotidienne la façonnage de la
mise en couleur un terrain rue avec des
engobes et là elle revient aux ados on a
parlé de la photo tout à l'heure pour
les plus grands il ya une préparation au
bafa ou si c'est ça alors ce stage est
reporté au mois de février - devrait
composer un peu plus tard peut-être plus
près les vacances d'été également au
plus tôt vous pouvez me démarque en vous
inscrire pour le stage qui se déroulera
du 23 et du samedi 23 au samedi 26
février
super pour retrouver toutes les
informations on a le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran vous
remercie beaucoup ri lerno d'être venu
sur notre cas merci à vous nous avons
donc retrouvé programme toutes les
activités des informations
supplémentaires ouvertes sur le site
internet du centre pour la première fois
le château de breteuil propose une
reconstitution historique de cinq
périodes militaires européennes du xiiie
siècle jusqu'à la seconde guerre
mondiale plus de 80 figurants costumés
seront présents tout le week end du 20
et 21 octobre et durant les vacances et
une école de sorciers qui va s'installer
à la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
onglons d'or sabota revers de leeuw sert
de coke
choisissez votre maison est passé
l'après-midi autour de différentes
activités du 20 octobre au 4 novembre
mois on reste dans le monde des sorciers
de harry potter le cinéma du grenier à
sel à celle de trappes le met au
programme pour les vacances
découvrez les autres films à l'affiché
avec patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
bonjour je vais vous parler des films
que nous aurons au grenier à sel pour
les vacances puisque ça commence très
bientôt nous avons pour commencer la
chasse à l'ours la chasse à l'ours est
un film d'animation que l'on peut voir
partir de 4 5 6 ans puisque c'est tiré
d'un livre jeunesse et qui est assez
connu une très belle comptines qui
restent dans la tête des enfants
elle était ce un ton très beau et un
beau une beau dessin pastel
nous avons aussi harry potter qui
revient sur les écrans ce n'est pas un
nouveau film ce sont les anciens films
qui sombrent numérisés restauré en
version 4 4 hd donc pour eux
pour qu'une nouvelle génération
d'enfants et d'adultes viennent voir
découvrir potter sur grand écran
vous les verrez cette pendant les
vacances nous avons aussi pour
diversifier pour les enfants un peu plus
grands à la 2 qui est la suite de aladin
donc avec kev adams qui cette fois va
affronter jamel debbouze qui est un
vilain et nous proposons aussi dit lily
à paris le dernier film de michel ocelot
michel ocelot c'est quand même le papa
de kirikou qui va bientôt avoir 20 ans
d'ailleurs jeudi entre parenthèses donc
vous pouvez découvrir dix lits à paris
très joli film très belle animation
d'une jeune kanak à paris qui va avoir
qu'il y avait plein aventures des
enquêtes etc et pour les encore plus
grands il y a
des séances de silent voice qui est un
film d'animation japonais vous retrouve
évidemment toutes les informations sur
notre site internet sylvain grenier à
sel points comme je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]
la première manche des mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste se déroule ce
week-end au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 52 pays seront
représentés 3 166 coureurs viendront
s'affronter et parmi eux les nids monte
et françois pervis sept fois champion du
monde portera les couleurs de la france
ils vous donnent rendez vous pour le
supporter dans cette étape importante
qui marque également le début de la
course à la qualification pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024
michael et demi d'euros lui a tendu le
micro à ses sur le public qu'ont à
domicile
il est vraiment on a des ailes qui nous
pousse notamment moi je m'en suis rendu
compte en 2015
physiquement j'étais mais n'était pas
vraiment au top et pourtant le public
m'a vraiment aidé ça m'a aidé à gagner
deux titres de champion du monde
ce que je veux quand je vous dis qu'il
ya 6000 personnes qui vous crie dessus
je peux vous dire que ça fait là est
vraiment la différence et tu te sens
j'étais en transe j'étais transcendé
je sentais plus mes jambes mais
mentalement ça donne un coup de boost
incroyable et j'ai hâte de pouvoir
revivre ça vous pouvez réserver vos
places sur la billetterie en ligne
sachez qu'un tarif préférentiel est
proposée aux saint quentinois
si vous venez directement au guichet du
vélodrome nationale avec un justificatif
de domicile
on reste dans la compétition avec la
finale régionale de breakdance samedi 20
novembre à la merise à trappes
elle accueille le championnat bboy
france pour les artistes l'inscription
se fait sur place à 11h30 pour le public
le show se déroule à 17h30 pour se
dégourdir aussi bien les mollets que les
poignets les clubs de choc roller hockey
et de tennis de table propose un stage
roller et tennis de table
préservez aux enfants de 6 à 11 ans les
inscriptions se font au guichet enfonce
éducation de l'hôtel de ville
[Musique]
cette semaine nous partons à l'institut
du monde arabe du 5e arrondissement de
paris l'exposition cité millénaire
voyage virtuel de palmyre à mossoul
propose un voyage en 3d à plus de 4000
km reportage de nicolas le herissier de
nos confrères via grand parent et
déambuler dans les ruines de palmyre la
perle du désert syrien admirer ces
temples et ses colonnades qui ont fait
la grandeur de la cité millénaire le
temps d'une exposition l'institut du
monde arabe ressuscite quatre lieux
chargés d'histoire
la plupart inscrits au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité ces dernières
années le patrimoine en monde arabe a
énormément souffert plus que jamais il
était important pour nous de
sensibiliser le public à cette question
l'un c'était un défi presque impossible
quand il s'agit de parler d'une
métropole 2 millions d'habitants comme
mossoul où alep ou d'un site
archéologique de 480 ha comme les
petites manies et donc on a eu l'idée de
travailler en collaboration avec la
société icon m qui numérise scan des
sites des villes ou des monuments pour
en faire des doubles numérique et donc
on s'est dit on va faire une exposition
complètement immersive où le visiteur va
pouvoir voir de ses propres yeux ce
patrimoine là les destructions qu'il a
subie mais aussi sa beauté dès le début
de l'exposition vous découvrirez mossoul
deuxième ville d'irak série désormais
désert ces habitations éventrées par les
bombardements et sa mosquée al douri
détruite à coups d'explosifs par
l'organisation état islamique
aujourd'hui les stigmates de la guerre
sont partout mais grâce à de nombreuses
photographies et des modélisations en 3d
la société française hypo n'aime t
revivre la ville martyrisée par les
combats c'est aussi le cas pour palmyre
joyau de syrie
avec tous les moyens d'acquisition
possibles et imaginables donc face sur
tous les appareils photo on prend des
images effectivement de tous tous les
recoins en quatre jours on a pu faire
des milliers des milliers d' image à la
fois du musée des différents un monument
qui ont été détruits de la colonnade
notre objectif c'est vraiment d'adapter
des technologies qui sont très récents 1
qui sortent des laboratoires quasiment à
des problématiques du terrain des
modélisations qui serviront peut-être
dans les prochains mois entamer la
reconstruction de ces sites millénaire
c'est la fin de ce numéro de votre 7,8
loisirs rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
et
bon
[Musique]